I like to blow my horn I'm going to be
showing you how to change your bag done
The Adventures of the bubble hat who's
your preseason Superbowl pick seagulls
the seagulls
you could have convinced me that was an
in memoriam like the Jonas Brothers once
a year tosh point-o reunites a group of
people that nobody gives a about
this season it's an inventor who's
studying concussions by bashing his head
in the marvelous mrs. poop bag and a
singing snowflake libbed heart who's hit
song was so catchy and infuriating but
it definitely gave Trump at least
Pennsylvania and of course my lovely
beard Fanny I don't kiss and tell but if
you ask nicely I will do charades that's
why I hosted the first ever Tosh con for
this year's tosh point-o that's what
they're up to now redemption reunion
spectacular
[Applause]
and so much thank you
where can I kiss you for 326 dollars
[Applause]
welcome to talk now let's bring out my
first panelist he loves the seagulls but
hates concussions it's Shannon was
coming on my show the greatest thing
that ever happened to you absolutely it
was you inspired me went home and did
the real deal so this is the real deal
yes sir
this is 3/8 aluminum and it's only 15
pounds that's only 15 pounds the whole
thing yeah any blind spots in there
that's the whole point that's why I
chose this I can every way one of those
huge camel bumps in the back that's so
when you get slammed on your back can I
kick you in the head dude yeah there you
go think it's awesome do neighbors ever
ask why you're in the park running
headfirst into trees you don't care what
anybody is doing until a gun is pointed
at your head was a good story is this
patent-pending I couldn't tell you put
it back on Kickstarter yeah currently
only $2 Kickstarter gives you exposure
what do you need to break even there's
no breaking even I know you say there's
no breaking even but I'm saying if they
were willing to take it to the next
level and reimburse you for your time
and expenses what would that number be
and I don't know how you put a price tag
I don't know either sanity but come up
with a price I don't know how to answer
that you just say a number yeah I can't
this is all heart man predictions for
the seagulls 2019 see the see you guys
there you go name five NFL teams right
now go Rams Rams
Rams Rams Patriots Patriots and then
49ers the 49ers Seahawks Seahawks bring
it home this is pressure there's two in
this goddamn City Packers there you go
all right let's take a few questions
from the audience for Shannon go ahead
hey Daniel big fan now please don't tell
me your dresses aren't here so she
commits to the character and cut your
balls off too sorry didn't mean to rile
you up there
I was just wondering how Shannon's
revolutionary iPhone kickstand invention
has come
I just put a hook on it that's all
what's next
first Shannon I want to build a
submarine car dammit Janet just when I
think I'm never gonna have you back here
it's called a supercar you get in your
car you drive into the ocean and then
you you go to make it a submarine this
could actually a little more practical
because you know absolutely nothing
about football thanks Shannon yeah duh
both now you might remember this next
young lady for carrying around her
digestive system in a ziplock bag give
it up for Laura okay let's shoot this
how full is your bag right now
completely empty I prepared for this
please tell America how much I've
changed your life for the better and
what a wonderful person I am I wish you
were joking you actually did change my
life for the better I got a call about
two days after it aired and it was a
president and CEO of this health care
company wanting to fly me out to
California to create an online place
where people with hasta Me's can receive
support
did you ever worry that my show wasn't
the right way to get your story out
there 100% Daniel yes I worried so much
but one of the main ways that I've
gotten through all that I've gotten
through is with a sense of humor and so
in the end I think it was actually the
perfect thing oh god you know yes okay
it's really gently it is keep that
finger inside has anyone touched it
since me
no you know what you are the only person
other than a doctor or a nurse I have
ever let touch it that's that's a great
great badge of honor let's take another
question from our audience I see we have
someone in a poorly made old-looking
Todd glass costume hilarious okay it's
not a costume it's me the real Todd
glass comedian author podcaster we are
all intimately familiar with their
credits Todd just asked your question my
questions for Daniel when are you gonna
be doing another installment of the
hugely popular sketch Todd Glass's awful
prank show trying to plan out my month
all right technically this counts as an
appearance you can go ahead and update
your on DB page
how long do you have to be dating
someone before you bring out the old
ostomy if you're going to take your
clothes off in front of someone they
need to know beforehand right so usually
I just start with my illness and how I
was so sick I almost died I have another
way that you can tell me prepare them I
got I need to talk to you this is very
serious blah blah blah and then just say
like I have full-blown AIDS then when
they they're like they process I'm just
kidding I have an ostomy and they're
like oh okay so the difference between a
comedian and a mental health counselor
you're right that's probably a bad way
to do it anyway thanks Laura hopefully a
thing heals up real soon
thank you that's not how this works here
now for our last panelist please welcome
the man behind the song that lost the
election for Hillary it's Paul have you
come to terms that Hillary will never be
in the house it took me a while at first
but I seem to have gotten my groove back
on do you blame yourself I bet people
asked me you know if I could have worked
any harder I mean I tried well what was
it like that night seeing Donald Trump
win in what many are saying is a
landslide electoral college victory I
just my gut was like oh is it gonna
happen is it gonna happen painfully and
it was very painful if he was sitting
here right now president Donald Trump
what would you say to him
how could you do this to us I mean who
gets away with this apparently the
president yeah I guess so
I just want to triple check something
last time you were here you mentioned
you had a wife he's splitting up with my
wife my first wife you know and I have a
question wife wife threw me there she's
still there okay can you sing us out
with a song just anything something
positive all I wanna do is kiss you kiss
you all I wanna do is hold your hand
all I wanna do is kiss you kiss you all
I wanna do is be a man white how about
another fan question what are you
supposed to be a little big fella
I'm your green screen get it ah green
screen with what appears to be herpes
very clever
I want your question so big-ass baby
that's just you in a mask right no if
that were true then explain this I'm one
big ass baby this show has gone off the
rails that's all the time we have thanks
to everyone for coming out to tosh con
see you next year plenty of footage for
a true crime documentary after one of
these psychos murders me I'm not talking
about you poopsie
you